you mentioned your son
bash who you know i think is
probably intellectually like one of the
smartest kids
that kid is how old is your son now
eight i wasn't saying he's probably
eight going on like 15
as far as his brain like he's a very
smart kid he's sharp
yeah he's a very sharp kid um you know i
i thought it was dope to see you do the
oreo commercial recently
um what is it about how you and amber
have raised him that
that you know i think i think to like
how i see
a lot of fathers with their kids and
like like what do you think is special
about how you guys decided to raise him
is there anything like that you would
give as far as like
advice to other parents out there um i
think we both share
a lot of the same views if not pretty
much all of them
on how he should be raised and
that's really important to be on the
same page with your partner
because you're you're trying you you
have to
there's a push in the pool some people
might want to see that kid grow up this
way some people might want to see it
grow up that way
and from what i've learned is that's
really just personal with the parents
and if you're grown enough and brave
enough to let that go for the better
of the kid then that's when they're able
to benefit
so you know there's some days where
he might not want to go to school and
she might be like all right cool
and if he's with her that's her rules
you dig what i'm saying right
all right cool your mom said some hooky
today yeah yeah
oh your mom blah blah blah you need to
be you like you completely let that go
and it is what it is
he's with me oh i mean we eat mcdonald's
today
you know she's like oh cool he deserves
a cheeseburger
he's been good right now don't be
feeding my baby you know what i mean
there's a lot of little
stuff that starts there the little stuff
like you gotta be able to get along and
then
when it comes to make big decisions then
you right there on the same page and
there's no friction
and um that's how me and her are as like
we we start with those little blocks and
he's a really good kid he's really
understanding he's really
you know fortunate we live right down
the street from each other right so he
gets to spend a lot of time with both of
us he's not really missing out on
too much so is he on the road blocks yo
he's robloxed out
being that roblox yeah he's he's roblox
in fortnite for